>> CHEERS!
LIKE MOST GAY MEN, I HAVE A LOT
OF STRAIGHT FEMALE FRIENDS, AND
I LOVE MY GIRLIES, BUT THEY CAN
BE A LOT, BOTH FINANCIALLY.
>> WAIT, CARSON, YOU'RE COMING
TO TULUM, RIGHT?
>> YOU KNOW IT, SIS.
AND EMOTIONALLY.
>> TULUM IS WHERE DYLAN AND I
WERE SUPPOSED TO GO BEFORE WE
BROKE UP.
>> I'M SO SORRY, BABE.
AS MUCH AS THESE GIRLS MEAN TO
ME, SOMETIMES I NEED A BREAK.
THAT'S WHEN I DISCOVERED,
STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND.
>> WHAT'S UP?
YO, WATCH ME HEAD CHOP THIS
BITCH.
BOOM TO THE DOOM.
>> AMAZING.
STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND IS A
LOW-EFFORT, LOW-STAKES
RELATIONSHIP THAT REQUIRES NO
EMOTIONAL COMMITMENT, NO
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT, AND OTHER
THAN THE OCCASIONAL VIDEO GAME
OUTBURST --
>> THIS GAME'S STUPID!
>> -- NO DRAMA.
>> YO, YOU WANT TO GO GET WINGS?
>> IF I DIDN'T CHECK IN WITH MY
GAL
PALS EVERY DAY OR TWO, IT WOULD
BECOME A WHOLE THING.
HANG OUT AS LITTLE OR AS MUCH AS
YOU WANT.
IT WON'T AFFECT THE FRIENDSHIP
AT ALL.
WATCH THIS.
HEY, I MIGHT BE MOVING TO EUROPE
FOR SEVEN YEARS.
>> DOPE.
JUST HIT ME WHEN YOU'RE BACK.
STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND IS EASY,
AND EVEN IF HE'S HAVING A TOUGH
TIME EMOTIONALLY, HE'LL NEVER
BRING ME INTO IT.
YOU OKAY?
YOU SEEM A LITTLE UPSET.
>> MAN, MY DAD DIED LAST WEEK.
>> OH.
>> BUT IT'S ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW?
>> YOU WANT TO GET SOME WINGS?
>> YEAH.
STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND ISN'T
PERFECT AND MAY ASK BLUNT
QUESTIONS ABOUT YOUR SEX LIFE.
>> SO DO GAY GUYS LIKE WHEN A
GUY HAS A BIG ONE, OR IS IT A
BAD THING?
>> DEPENDS ON THE GUY.
BUT HE'S ONLY ASKING BECAUSE
HE'S HONESTLY CURIOUS, AND
THERE'S SOMETHING SWEET ABOUT
THAT.
DOES STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND
PROVIDE THE SAME DEEP
RELATIONSHIP I HAVE WITH MY
GIRLS?
NO.
DOES STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND KNOW
MY LAST NAME?
NO.
THAT'S KIND OF THE BEAUTY OF
IT.
BUT IF YOU ARE MISSING A LITTLE
DRAMA, JUST SAY THIS.
I BET I'M FASTER THAN YOU.
>> DOG, BRO, FOR REAL?
YOU THINK YOU'RE FASTER THAN ME?
I WILL GO OUTSIDE ON THE STREET
AND DUST YOUR ASS RIGHT NOW.
LET'S GO.
COME ON.
>> SO IF YOU'RE A GAY MAN WHO
NEEDS A BREAK, COME ENJOY THE
CASUAL RELATIONSHIP GAY WOMEN
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT FOR YEARS.
STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND.
>> SORRY FOR BEING A PUSSY ABOUT
MY DAD DYING EARLIER.
THAT WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> STRAIGHT MALE FRIEND,
AVAILABLE EVERYWHERE.
EXCEPT THERAPY.